donc là aujourd'hui on est en slovaquie
obinna rome à bratislava
aujourd'hui on parle cyber sécurité par
contre c'est pas moi qui vais vous en
parler c'est mon pote guillaume qui
était à bratislava avec et z france il
n'y a pas très longtemps si vous
intéressait vraiment aux questions de
cybersécurité
franchement vous allez être gâtés vous
allez voir c'est super intéressant et en
plus de ça guillaume nous régaler nous
invite à découvrir un petit peu
bratislava donc là franchement vous
allez en prendre plein les yeux
[Musique]
c'est une journée pleine de conférence
on va parler de steve net lojack donc
que target pas mal les entreprises
militaires le secteur le secteur
militaire les gouvernements souverains
est très très grosse organisation on a
eu aussi fait un petit tour avec green
energy a black energy donc des attaques
qui visaient plutôt des entreprises
énergétiques ont été black out en
ukraine et tout ça on a attaqué avec la
sécurité de des objets connectés à
internet of things ça on va reparler
évidemment plus en détails et en fait on
a réparé l'écriteau monnaie et donc tu
te prennes 6 et et comment fait quelques
attaques peuvent se retrouver à faire
avoue aminé contre votre gré sur
et le chien bonjour benoît salut est ce
que tu peux te présenter dans un premier
temps mais bien sûr je suis directeur
des opérations chez les aides france
nous a parlé de toute attaque qui visait
des gouvernementaux des entreprises
militaires nous a mentionné terme sydnet
loggia qu'est ce que tu peux nous en
dire un peu plus sur ce qu'ils
s'agissaient et le lien avec avec les
est le premier lien c'est que et êtes en
ce qui concerne l'autre jacques a
découvert la première menace qui
s'attaque à lui est englué fille c'est
ce qui assure une carte mère
car avant on appelait c'était le bios ça
a évolué et aujourd'hui ça permet à la
machine de démarrer serra vendus c'est
une sorte de mini sites à l'exploitation
avant même que windows ou linux ou
n'importe quel autre système se lance et
cette menace là est attribué un groupe
qu'on appelle scénique et ce groupe en
fait est soupçonné ce que les
attributions sont toujours difficiles
car le dire c'est lui celui-ci lui
c'était le pays
non on ne fait pas simplement parce
qu'on s'arrête pas à un moment où on a
des preuves techniques mais on se sait
pas qui est derrière ça c'est le travail
de la police à cenon chercheurs ont
trouvé ces gens là debout tu as il a
trouvé le premier pyrrhus catégorie
rockit système caché qui devient maître
de la machine en route et qui s'en prend
à lui et puis ce qui me dit en pratique
que si tu enlèves le disque dur que tu
réinstalle windows que tu réinstalle
ligne sous crois que tu fasses en fait
comme c'est sur la carte de merde ça
revient sur le nouveau système que tu
installe donc la machine est perdu alors
après il faut mettre à jour le firmware
avec un nouveau firmware ou infirmières
qui revient à l'ancien qui était propre
mais concrètement ou et on peut dire que
la machine à l'est déjà pour faire une
attaque comme comme ça de lojack ça le
la complexité d'aller modifier le
firmeware donc vraiment la carte mère à
distance ça nécessite un certain nombre
d'enseignements de techniques et d'
analyse
sont pas à la portée du premier venu et
en plus ce qui nécessite du temps et
donc le temps c'est comment c'est de
l'argent et si tu veux pouvoir
travailler longtemps sur une menace en
tout cas un objectif ray et bien il te
faut il te faut du financement et le
financement soit tu le tu là parce que
tu es oeuvre dans d'autres endroits
quelqu'un arrive avec je peux au moins
dire en somme - hier à gagner beaucoup
d'argent tout casser pour se financer et
du coup tu as du temps pour faire cette
menace là mais vu la cible qui est
derrière généralement tu dis quand même
que c'est pas monsieur tout le monde qui
concerne le dire
derrière moi un château magnifique à
bratislava en slovaquie c'est absolument
sublime
ce qui est sûr c'est que bien entendu
les op énergétique et on peut imaginer
je peux pas faire ce scénario
catastrophe parce que je pourrais y
passer des heures mais l'eau potable
enfin il ya tellement d'infrastructures
ce que nous on appelle en france les
olives et opérateurs d'importance vitale
les olives et fournissent des zones et
des biens des services d'importance
vitale et ils sont extrêmement conscient
le gouvernement français en a vraiment
extrêmement conscience et ils sont
protégés monitorer aider d'une manière
bien spécifique
il ya une échelle de temps qui n'est pas
la même que celle que l'on peut avoir
dans une start-up si on prend vraiment
l'opposé dans l'environnement industriel
quels qu'ils soient mais en partie chez
les olives et à des échelles de temps
qu'ils sont énormes
allez 10 ans et une petite échelle de
temps quand tu achète des équipements
qui coûtent des millions voire des
milliards pour produire de l'énergie
si tu fais pas enfin têtu qui votent pas
tu pivote pas tous les trois en disant à
mon marché a changé fait du coup si à un
moment dire mais vous savez là ça votre
matériel il est sorti il ya six mois il
est obsolète c'est compliqué à gérer
mais pour autant il est guidé mesure où
tu vas protéger ce qui est autour pas
forcément l'équipement les mairies dans
le cas présent donc greenergy black
energy sélestat le nom qu'on a donné à
des attaques ça qu'est ce qu'ils ont
donner concrètement et qu'est-ce que
quelles mesures ont pu être appliquée
derrière ils combien il est intervenu
peut-être nous on intervient dans ce
type de d'attac surtout sur gré énergie
on intervient soit après parce qu'on
constate et malheureusement on n'a pas
pu intervenir à temps soit ce qui est
bien sûr gré énergie c'est qu'on
intervient avant c'est à dire que quand
tu as une menace surtout de cette
ampleur là tu es obligé créer une
infrastructure est obligé de te préparer
à attaquer et on a réussi à choper les
éléments qui nous ont fait comprendre
qu'il allait y avoir quelque chose de
potentiellement très très impactant
notamment sur l'énergie enfin et signe
avant coureur des preuves etc et on a
réussi à arrêter la menace avant
qu'elles ne soient rentrés en action
pourtant ils allaient commencer à la
déployer à un triplé vers quel pays
alors ben c'était ukraine et pologne on
est sur des choses qu'il dépasse la
fiction parfois et sur des enjeux qui
sont juste une heure au mr au mode saas
au quotidien ces deux là c'est la cyber
diable à l'aide d'un emploi
c'est place à moissannes avant cela veut
dire qu'ils s'apprêtent à les manger
dans une galerie d'art c'est bien de ça
tour d'horizon toujours tourné au oui
mais en vain aux guerres un peu je
trouve des fois on va attaquer internet
of things les objets connectés et la
vulnérabilité de nos objets connectés
on peut parler des ampoules philippe
souffert des indices importants pour que
vous avez caméras connectées à des
enceintes connectés effectivement les la
lampe tout cela maisons et connectés
d'une manière générale quand tu parles
un fall de domotique est là tous
connectés chez lui qu'est ce qu'on peut
en dire côté côté cybersécurité côté
cyberattaques contre des actes néfastes
qui peuvent en déduire de de mon ancien
de connecter de ma caméra connectés je
dirais que la première chose c'est que
il n'y a pas de psychose parce que la
came ta caméra ou ton ancien de
connecter et conduire le l'impact que
cela peut avoir une caméra c'est
peut-être un peu différent parce que
doublé ont peu de films et tu veux te
promener chez toi tenu par exemple bon
c'est un peu plus embêtant une enceinte
connectés c'est moins embêtant alors les
volets si par exemple quelqu'un arrive à
prendre le contrôle de thé volet huit
ans ferme chez toi ou on c'est embêtant
aussi mais globalement déjà si on
regarde et si on retourne à la
cyberguerre globalement à l'échelle d'un
pays c'est pas c'est pas hyper gênant
par contre à l'échelle personnel oui ça
peut être embêtant mais l'idée en fait
ce serait combinée de faire une armée à
l'ordre elle est connectée d'ailleurs
effectivement là tu vas tu vas dans le
scénario où effectivement un attaquant
va pouvoir les utiliser
non pas un concours quoi parce que toi
et moi on n'a pas d'intérêt et
d'importance mais par contre tous les
utiliser les mettre les uns avec les
autres et puis du coup j'ai une armée de
bottes qui vont
pouvoir et d'ailleurs on l'a vue des
caméras ip avait été utilisé pour faire
du d'eidos c'est à dire les dénis de
service sur des services essentiels
d'internet les dns etc et ça avait
paralysé de mémoire c'était paypal et
puis d'autres devant de sony sony aussi
playstation on va se dire oui oui tout à
fait est ce que qu'on peut retrouver
quelque part un endroit qui me dit c'est
marca ces produits là sont pas protégés
cela son protégé donc qu'est-ce qu'on
qu'est ce qu'on peut faire pour
s'assurer d'avoir un produit
potentiellement correct je dirais que en
tant que acheter un responsable tu va
mener son enquête que tu l'as vu c'est
une étude que l'on a pu riait on a pris
une dizaine de vieilles le produit et on
les a testées et comme on est
responsable les fois qu'on a les a
testées on a averti le fabricant en lui
disant voilà ce que l'on a trouvé on va
te laisser un mois deux mois trois mois
le temps qu'il faut pour mettre à jour
pour corriger ces trucs là comme ça ça
veut dire que même si toi tu avais ce
site what u à ce produit là où si tu
comptes l'acheter mais normalement la
nouvelle version qui sera plus efficace
si tu achètes un matériel sérieux avec
la femme par un fabricant sérieux il va
le faire et c'est un peu le conseil
c'est de dire on va trouver un fabricant
sérieux et dans l'internet offs il ya
toujours eu une course à la
miniaturisation à ce que quand tu
achètes une caméra chinoises par exemple
no name à 39,2 euros bas
dans un mini ordinateur un capteurs des
diodes qui met de l'infrarouge
ça coûte plus cher mais tout ça mis bout
à bout 39 euros c'est vraiment pas cher
et donc ça veut dire que dans le process
de développement
il ya un moment où il faut juste faire
l'impasse sur quelque chose est bien
souvent malheureusement l'impasse et la
sécurité la crypte ont mené les colts
ockrent 6 nous a présenté un petit
boîtier qui nous mais j'avoue j'étais un
peu perturbé sur son fonctionnement
s'il a largué mineurs en fait si on veut
résumer assez simplement la situation
c'est que on a commencé par montrer des
courbes qui montrait que le commentaire
le gain que tu vas faire si toi ou moi
particulier on se met à miner
aujourd'hui avec le coût de
l'infrastructure le coût de
l'électricité et le coût d'une manière
générale pour miner le coût de l'achat
du matériel
et bien en fait c'est plus rentable et
ça reste rentable si tu me payes pas le
matériel
si tu ne payes pas l'électricité ça veut
dire que tu es un pirate et que tu prend
le contrôle de une deux trois dix 20 300
machines machine au sens large du terme
une télé le petit boîtier comme davud
enfin et du coup en fait une mine mais
tu payes tu n'as pas de coûts de minage
et donc du coup là ça devient rentable
et la cdu bien pur mais voilà c'était la
présentation c'était pour expliquer
parce que souvent on se dit mais par
exemple où tout le monde parle de
bitcoin département et le crypto jacking
ça c'est une des menaces qui est en
passe de remplacer laurent somewhere
c'est vraiment important parce que
laurent sur mer si toi et moi on a un
sommaire ça va nous de finir le grand
sourire
c'est la menace qui arrive sur ton
ordinateur et qui va chiffres étaient
donnés cette année rendre intelligible
tu vois bull y accéder il va te demander
une rançon
en somme - et si tu payes c'est rançon
déjà nous nous la communauté ainsi
versée qu conseille de ne pas payer
lorsque tu commences a dealé avec des
pirates donc que baky des pirates ledit
témoin sur des preuves et en argent pas
forcément de code d'honneur et
l'affection de délivrer la célèbre et
voire même on a vu des logiciels qui ne
l'avait pas de mécanisme pour donner à
quai certes même si tu payes de toute
façon tu payes un pirate et le mec il a
juste chiffres et qu'on disque dur et
est donc et donc leur en somme c'est
pour les pirates c'est plutôt bien ça
leur a rapporté pas mal d'argent mais on
sent que nous éditeurs vécu la
communauté arrive de mieux en mieux à se
protéger
par contre donc ils se sont dit comment
est ce qu'on va faire de l'argent
pareil on en revient là si derrière on
en revient aux premières étapes comment
est ce que je vais travailler à financer
mes activités et la crypto monette une a
été une bonne voie et en fait le la
plupart des gens vont se dire bah moi si
je demain j'ai un crypto une clé un
crypto de jacqueline fehr quelqu'un qui
va utiliser ma télé mon auteur mon
ordinateur pour crypter de la monnaie
miné de la monnaie pardon en fait je
m'en fiche parce que ça ne m'empêche pas
d'aller surfer sur internet ou de faire
utiliser ma machine normalement et le
souci c'est que si tu laisses faire mais
ça veut dire que battu participe au
financement des cybercriminels par
défaut
petit tour
une galerie d'art qui propriété d'un des
fondateurs de dz sécurité large
collection d'oeuvres exposées là on
n'est que dans une des salles il ya
quatre ou cinq étages comme l'indiqué un
des représentants de la marque liga avec
la cybersécurité c'est 300 mille
nouvelles menaces injectées chaque jour
dans notre cyber monde dans des machines
alors par des machines parce
qu'effectivement il faut il faut de la
puissance pour créer des nouvelles
menaces et par des cybercriminels et du
coup nous aussi on doit être capable
d'analyser ces trois cent mille
nouvelles menaces chaque jour et pour ça
il ya un moment on a beau avoir fait
chanter presse de centre de r&d à
travers le monde à l'évènement s'est pas
capable quand c'est pas impossible
et du coup le machine learning bahari
des et va avec
on a trente années d'existence ce pays
depuis 80 ans depuis trente années on
prend les virus et on dit ça ça des rues
ça c'est pas un virus un virus sasser
pas un virus sasser une bonne catégorie
et en fait on crée un modèle qui va
classer ces menaces qui va évoluer en
fonction des nouvelles menaces que l'on
va trouver et qui va nous permettre
d'aller très rapidement dans la
classification et nous priver notamment
300 millions à quel point c'est
compliqué ou simple de faire appel à
vous de dire ben voila moi j'ai une gêne
pme de je sais pas trente employés je
travaille avec beaucoup de données que
je récupère et est même pas besoin de
beaucoup de données pour subir une
attaque et avoir une crise de nerfs
comment on veut faire appel à eset tout
d'autres en j'imagine que vous n'êtes
pas la seule sur le marché
pour cela on a une petite spécificité
sur le sur la partie chiffrement s'est
toujours vu comme un empêcheur de
tourner en rond parce que si je chiffres
moi si j'ai pas les bons mécanismes bats
toi tu pourras pas y accéder ce qui peut
être bien citer un pirate
mais si on travaille ensemble ça va être
compliqué et notamment il ya pas mal de
solutions libres ou pas qui existent
sont plutôt efficaces mais qui pose le
problème de la collaboration est ce que
proposait jette c'est de dire toi et moi
et un autre ou pas et là on va avoir des
cons et c'était là c'est comme un
coffre-fort poussée des clés qui vont
nous permettre de chiffres et nos
données
et en fait on va voir un serveur qui va
permettre de partager les quais et de
dire l'administrateur le chef de
l'entreprise va dire vous deux vous avez
droit travaillent ensemble et puis lui
il a pas le droit de voir mais je
travaille avec lui la compta travail
avec le marketing le marketing travail
etc etc
et de là comme ça on va pouvoir mettre
en place un système de clé où chacun va
avoir accès à des données mais
uniquement les données autorisé par la
nuit en termes de plus on parle de
détail pour une trentaine d'euros par
utilisateur par an par là et il ya un
autre truc est important chez est sûr
c'est que avant même d'aller jusque là
on propose une solution qui s'appelle
full disk en cription c'est à dire le
chiffrement complet de ce qui veut dire
que quand tu ouvres ton ordinateur
portable j'ai dit que l'ordinateur vente
avec quand tu allumes la machine et
vient en fait l'accord chose que j'ai à
faire c'est qu'il va mettre un mot de
passe et ensuite parce que tandis que
chiffres et ensuite mon disque
passionnés chiffres n'ont hélas tu vas
travaillons de manière nous complètement
normal et le fait que ton juste que
soient chiffrées
tu vas pas être obligé de te dire un
moment mais ça c'est sensible c'est pas
sensible est ce que je le mets dans un
dossier chypre où est-ce que tout ton
disque est chiffré ce qui veut dire que
si jamais tu et à l'ordinateur
et bien en fait c'est illisible donc tu
répond aux exigences du rgp des méta
même pas posé de questions comment vous
collaborez comment vous répondez aux
appels de des forces de l'ordre qui vous
contactent sachant qu'en plus on nous a
indiqué que étant donné que les
intérieurs partout dans le monde mais
que c est son siège et est en slovaquie
oui et l'ont convaincue qu'il faut que
la demande arrive jusqu'en slovaquie
c'est ce qu'a voulu descendre jusqu'à 1
to d'où l'intérêt pour les forces de
l'ordre de travailler au clairet avec
interpol quand tu te fais voler son
ordinateur
le seul qui se fait voler son ordinateur
dit j'avais j'avais et êtes me trompe
sur ma machine
et quand la machine s'allume avec un peu
de chance les aide à se mettre à jour à
dire et je suis est ce qu'il ya un
nouvelle version du logiciel et il ya
sur nos serveurs on va voir l'adresse ip
depuis laquelle il a demandé ça et ça
c'est utilisé dans les enquêtes pour
dire
mais monsieur vous été volé votre
ordinateur je regarde où il la dernière
adresse ip est parfois aidé à celui qui
a volé la machine ou celui qui l'a
revendu allume la machine est là en un
sens l'adresse ip on élabore en
départements peuvent faire leur travail
dans nos produits il ya un petit truc
qui s'appelle antivol le mode antivol et
le mode antivol la première chose qu'il
fait c'est qu'ils te demande de créer un
compte sur le cloud
parce que si tu as plus accès à son
ordinateur il faut bien qu'à un moment
du bisse dire à nos systèmes lg plus mon
ordinateur et ensuite ils te créer une
session fantôme
c'est à dire un compte invité sans mot
de passe ou tu peux aller n'importe qui
notamment celui et celui qui trouve
l'ordi de l'ordinateur peut se connecter
et ça c'est un point important aussi
c'est que en france on est un des rares
pays a acquis la fonction antivol sert
plus à retrouver des machines perdu et
n'ont volé et non volés avec wana cry
déjà est ce que j'avais vu un boom et du
business chez z chiffre peut-être qu'on
peut partager ou pas du tout quelqu'un
de sympa que ça lui que je crois qu'ils
ont des intérêts
nous a dit voilà je suis dont anna
crighton téléphone a complètement
explosé d'appel parce que les hôpitaux
britanniques étaient en cours jacno ans
l'ancien l'ancien officier de police
maintenant je peux pas de chiffres et
financièrement l'instant vous avez
durant mais on le voit notamment sur les
blogs les blogs de type wifi security ou
tu retrouve donc les recherches que
faisais tu es et ce blog la la le
visitorat purement explosé et ça c cnet
et surtout parce qu on a aussi compris
nous aussi un que la cyber security
s'est passé mais en même temps tu peux
pas vivre dans un monde connecté la
journée sur la table dans les rues on a
quatre téléphones il ya des caméras
vidéo partout les lumières sont
certainement piloté par quelque chose
d'automatique tu quittes tu peux pas vit
dans un monde connecté et ne pas te
soucie de la cybersécurité et du coup
c'est aussi nous rendus compte que on
travaillait depuis des années avec les
entreprises ont partagé les mêmes
problématiques et qui à un moment il
fallait aussi est descendu d'un cran et
participer à l'éducation l'information
de tout le monde de tout le monde crie
aujourd'hui que tu ne veuilles ou non
étaient connectés parce que les acomptes
tu peux encore payer par chèque tu peux
encore aller à la perception mais il ya
un moment ben voila tu cliques sur un
bouton tafer le virement et d'habilité
un peu c'est quand même vachement
pratiquement et du cou et du coup au par
exemple en france on participe à cyber
malveillance point fr c'est une
plateforme qui est une coopération
encore une fois entre les forces de
l'ordre et et mais plein de boîtes
privées
j'ai microsoft orange la fédération
française de l'assurance et du coup
super malveillance point gouv.fr à une
objectif c'est d'être un peu
l'équivalent de la sécurité routière et
de dire voilà les menaces qui pèsent sur
vos grands publics ou petites et
moyennes entreprises
voilà comment vous protéger quels sont
les bons réflexes et ses îles c'est
pareil c'est lassant
enfin internet c'est comme la sécurité
routière quand les voitures sont apparus
il n'y avait pas de ceinture il n'y
avait pas de les freins et des poids
terrible mais en même temps il n'y a pas
beaucoup de voitures donc le risque
d'accident la limite celui qui risquait
plus c'était le piéton parce que la
voiture avait pas s'arrêter et puis du
coup il est bonne voiture donc il a
fallu faire un code de la route
mettez en place des règles et tout ça et
puis dire au bn vous devez voiture
allait plus en plus vite donc vous devez
mettre une ceinture pour vous protéger
et avec le cyber malveillants sont
engouffrés et internet
bon on espère la même chose il faut
avoir conscience que c'est génial mais
qu' il ya des désavantages de levroux
des désagréments et qu'il faut y aller
en toute connaissance de cause
voilà une série qui s'appelle la cible
sur regarde non pas ça la cia la base
vers un virus physique
il ya pas mal éradiquer toute la planète
la nouvelle saison démarre avec l'amiral
qui dit voilà qui reçoivent une thèse
d'un étudiant qui dit la prochaine
guerre mondiale sera cyberguerre
évidemment quinze minutes après la
paralysie totale du réseau américain qui
fait qu' ils se prennent une attaque
monstrueuse et qui perdent quasiment
toute leur flotte militaire
on peut s'accorder sur le fait que ce
passage de série mais complètement vrai
en fait t'as pas besoin de tuer il est
militaire parce que tu l'aies tu les as
ta merci imagine tu veux prendre
d'assaut un pays certes été un pays très
hostile et hudima ok moi mon voisin je
vais me le faire et je vais envahir son
pays
en fait si tu pars ali ses
infrastructures et que par exemple tu
dis va écouter s'il sent bien soit
vous me donnez le pays ça veut dire que
mme archange annexes votre pays c'est ça
devient un seul et grand pays soit je
coupe l'accès à vos populations à l'eau
potable qu'ils vont mourir parce que
l'eau potable c'est quand même
voilà soit je coupe l'électricité 6 c en
hiver et mourir de froid et c est donc à
partir de là tu as même pas besoin de
sortir les chars d'assaut
tu dis maintenant vous prenez les armes
vous les et pc et vous n'ouvrez la porte
pour que je puisse venir prendre ma
place à l'elysée par exemple parce que
je sais en france et du coup tu as tu
peux tu peux faire une cyber guerre et
prendre un pays avec zéro mort il ya des
discussions avec les grands ministre de
l'intérieur il y en a il y en a moi je
dirais que là où on a quand même de la
chance c'est que déjà en france on est
bien protégé notre maman le lundi 6
femmes au boulot les entreprises sont
responsables etc
après on peut tous se venger des
attaques par ci par là mais globalement
on est quand même c'est quand même on
doit protéger et et surtout arriver à
prendre d'assaut tout un pays lui mais
heureusement on n'en est pas encore là
je pense qu'on a encore quelques années
devant nous a donc ça soit vraiment
complet on pourrait se dire bah tiens
voilà peut-être que là il ya quelque
chose d'une industrie qui est vulnérable
une partie qui est vulnérable
de là à prendre le contrôle la réseau de
rêve du réseau de nos ministères je suis
comme ça on a encore quelques années
tranquillement encore une fois merci à
elle et de sécurité darina benoît toute
l'équipe de france merci de nous avoir
invités en slovaquie en fait les
arrangements nécessaires pour que je
puisse découler depuis londres et pas
depuis paris ce leurre que la vidéo a pu
comme dirait mon ami oreiller impliqués
monsieur ben messaoud bleus lâché un
commentaire abonnez vous
[Musique]